madame monsieur bonsoir grande première
médicale aux états unis où une équipe
vient d'établir l'existence d'un lien
génétique direct entre la fumée du tabac
et le développement des cancers
découverte qui devrait relancer les très
nombreux procès opposant les défenseurs
de la santé aux industriels de la
cigarette
sébastien muller on savait bien entendu
qu'il existait un lien entre le cancer
du poumon et la fumée du tabac
de nombreux tests sur les fumeurs
l'indiquait mais jusqu'à présent ce lien
génétique direct n'avait jamais été
identifié ni prouvée scientifiquement
c'est chose faite aujourd'hui au coeur
d'une cellule humaine il existe parmi
beaucoup d'autres
le gène p53 qui protège précisément
contre les tumeurs
l'étude américaine démontre que le
benzopyrène sorte de goudron
cancérigènes présent dans la fumée
attaque directement le gène p53 du coup
la cellule n'est plus immunisée et
devient cancéreuses
cette découverte est une véritable
aubaine pour les scientifiques qui lutte
contre le cancer depuis des années les
industries du tabac prétendent qu'il n'y
a pas de relation de cause à savon le
contraire et cette étude établit de
façon définitive ce sont bien les
industriels de la cigarette qui sont à
nouveau mis en cause tous les procès qui
les oppose aujourd'hui aux victimes du
tabac risque d'être relancé par cette
preuves scientifiques incontestables
attention ce n'est pas une grande
découverte en matière de diagnostic et
de traitement du cancer
nous en sommes encore loin pas de faux
espoirs donc pour les victimes du cancer
il s'agit simplement de l'identification
du mal mais c'est une vérité
scientifique aux conséquences
économiques incalculables